Could a post-slap Will Smith win another Oscar?
Is "Emancipation" based on a true story?
Here's all you need to know before seeing
Smith's next big film.
In just a few months, Will Smith's historical
drama "Emancipation" will be hitting theaters
and dropping on Apple TV+, and there are already
people with extremely high hopes for the emotionally-charged
action epic.
Based on a true story, "Emancipation" is intended
to shine a light on the United States' most
turbulent time in history — the American
Civil War and the height of slavery in the South.
Early reactions to the film have so far been
very strong, with most people who've seen
it offering up immense praise for the subject
matter and themes on social media.
According to Deadline, a private screening
of "Emancipation" was held in early October
by Apple Original Films and the NAACP.
Members of the Congressional Black Caucus,
Historically Black College and Universities,
the Divine 9, National Council of Negro Women,
the National Coalition on Black Civic Participation,
and other prominent groups were invited.
On October 24, Smith also held a private screening
of "Emancipation" for some of his celebrity
friends, including Rihanna, Dave Chapelle,
and A$AP Rocky. Smith later took to his Instagram
page to commemorate the event, saying:
"EPIC night!!
Thanx for coming to see #Emancipation.
Hope ya'll enjoyed!!"
But what everyone wants to know is when the
public can actually see the historical film.
According to Apple, "Emancipation" will get
a limited release in theaters on December
2 before hitting Apple TV+ on December 9,
which is right in time for awards season.
Film experts and critics expect Will Smith,
despite his 2022 Oscar controversy, to still
be in the running for another gold statue
next year.
Associate professor of film studies at the
University of Sydney, Bruce Isaacs, tweeted,
"There is HUGE oscar buzz around #Emancipation."
For those who somehow missed what happened
at the Academy Awards, Smith basically turned
his entire life and career upside down.
He did so with a swift slap to the face of
comedian Chris Rock following a joke that
Rock made about Smith's wife, Jada Pinkett
Smith.
Rock, who was on stage presenting an award,
had poked fun at Jada for having a shaved
head, which is reportedly due to alopecia.
Smith would later apologize for his actions
in an Instagram statement, saying his behavior
was, quote, "unacceptable and inexcusable."
He also released a recorded response on YouTube
in July 2022 that featured multiple apologies
to both Rock and his family.
"This is probably irreparable."
With "Emancipation" not coming out until December,
many experts feel like there's been enough
time and apologies made by Smith for him to
snag another Best Actor award at next year's
Oscars, especially given the movie's subject
matter.
"Emancipation" is a film that centers around
an enslaved man from the 1860s who escapes
from a plantation and travels across the swamps
of Louisiana to reunite with his family.
It's ultimately based on the true story of
"Whipped Peter," who became famous during
that time period for a picture that was taken
of his severely scarred and whipped back.
The image was published in the Independent
and Harper's Weekly and helped open the nation's
eyes to the horrors of slavery, especially
in the South.
Screenwriter Bill Collage reportedly used
Civil War-era documents and Peter's very own
diaries to help pen the script.
Back in September 2021, Will Smith spoke to
GQ magazine about what drew him to the "Emancipation"
story, despite being hesitant to do movies
about slavery in the past.
This includes "Django Unchained," which he
famously turned down.
Smith said,
"This was one that was about love and the
power of Black love.
And that was something that I could rock with.
We were going to make a story about how Black
love makes us invincible."
The official Apple Studios description of
"Emancipation" describes Smith's Peter as
a slave who manages to escape from a Louisiana
plantation after being almost whipped to death.
It further reads,
"He had to outwit cold-blooded hunters and
the unforgiving swamps of Louisiana on a torturous
journey north."
In addition to Will Smith, "Emancipation"
is set to feature a number of familiar faces.
"Hell or High Water" and "3:10 to Yuma" star
Ben Foster is slated to play a slave hunter
named Fassel.
Legendary character actor Steven Ogg will
be portraying a man named Sergeant Howard.
Other cast members include Charmaine Bingwa,
Gilbert Owuor, Mustafa Shakir, Grant Harvey,
Timothy Hutton, Michael Luwoye, and several
others.
Speaking to The Guardian in April 2022, Foster
described how the story that inspired "Emancipation"
had really moved and resonated with him, especially
since he had just finished making Barry Levinson's
"The Survivor" about real-life Auschwitz survivor
and boxer Harry Haft.
Foster said,
"[Emancipation's] about escaping the camps
that America created with the African American
slave trade.
The stark similarities that I learned, particularly
after visiting Auschwitz, are staggering.
We are students and, as students.
It's not uncommon to feel a burden of new
information and it takes a moment to digest."
Legendary "Training Day" director Antoine
Fuqua is ultimately the one responsible for
bringing "Emancipation" to life, with him
serving as both director and executive producer
on the film.
He spoke to Deadline in-depth over the summer
about what inspired him to get in the director's
chair and how the story of "Whipped Peter"
is something that moved him both as a filmmaker
and a person.
Fuqua said,
"It was the first viral image of the brutality
of slavery that the world saw.
It's almost two years now from when I first
read the script.
It hit my heart and my soul in so many ways
that are impossible to convey."
He explained how Whipped Peter's story hit
close to home because of its family themes
— Peter, after all, wouldn't give up until
he returned to his family.
"I will look in triumph…
at my enemies."